hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 132 not even
close to prime
uh we are obviously in a remote location
it has uh i believe we've got the tech
set up to work properly but we are a
little bit hobbled by some of the
constraints of this location anyway
please bear with us
we are excited to be
podcasting from here a slight delay for
those of you who are watching live but
um i think it's all good to go i think
it's all good to go any snoring that you
hear is not coming from your own living
room i hope but it is coming from our
lovely labrador it was just off screen
here uh and uh
and indeed yes here you go i don't think
we can guarantee them that any snoring
they hear is not in their own living
room because there could be somebody
snoring there as well oh okay there's
you see that the dog is for real yeah
um so today we're going to talk a bit
about
roe being overturned
as
as
we had good reason to think it was going
to be and we talked about extensively in
an earlier episode we're going to be
talking about
twitter sanctioned violence and a bit
about the cdc
and vares that's a lot of initials
that's the centers for disease control
and it was at the center it was the
centers for disease control and of
course the vaccine adverse events
reporting system
so and the connections between all of
those things which interestingly this
week they all do link up indeed as is so
often the case
so we will despite being from a unusual
place because we're doing it this normal
time we will do a q a right afterwards
you can ask questions at
darkhorseammissions.com
we encourage you to seek out a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century which is now available not just
in english which is the language we
wrote it in but also in spanish and in
french
if you're watching on youtube you can
find the live chat on odyssey
you can find our new le tour de france
it's like bike racing on steroids shirts
at our store
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
but if you'd rather
wait a week or two we're gonna have a
brand new store uh with uh more
consistent quality and uh a little bit
uh a little bit less censorship so uh
we're excited about that a lot less
censorship yeah actually a lot like uh
infinitely less
infinitely little how's that i'm not
infinitely little
um
yep we've got
i always point you to natural selections
which is where i do my sub stack i was
talking last week about discussion of
sex versus ancestry understanding uh our
ancestry uh from an individual
perspective versus a population
perspective the kind of thinking that
one has to begin to get a game facility
with in order to think evolutionarily
and uh finally by way of introductions
and logistics we are supported by our
audience we appreciate you subscribing
liking sharing both our full episodes on
youtube or odyssey or spotify or clips
at darkhorsepodcastclips at both youtube
and odyssey
and just a reminder that last summer of
course youtube demonetized us and they
have not re-monetized us uh although
there were glimmers of hope possibly as
such we do as always also appreciate
your financial support if you can afford
it you can for instance join one of our
patreons
uh very tomorrow very tomorrow so very
tomorrow is our monthly private q a
which we'll be doing
at 11 o'clock 11 a.m to 1 p.m pacific
time from the same location where we're
coming to you at from now
uh
from
yes wow it's very colloquial around you
i guess it is
uh
the questions have already been asked
for that but it's a it's a small enough
group that we're able to engage with the
chat and answer questions sometimes they
come up there as it's a lot of fun you
can find access to that at my patreon
next
next weekend brett will be doing
conversations associated with his
patreon
and um
and you can also access our wonderful
discord community at either of them you
can engage in honest conversations about
difficult topics join a book club
unwind with virtual happy hairs and even
karaoke this is this is from people on
the discord who tell me this young or
old left or right there's a spot for you
around the campfire one more note i
forgot to make at the top of the hour
we are not going to be here next
saturday we're doing a wednesday episode
saturday after wednesday after next
saturday so
we're going to have a slightly wonky
schedule here again
shortly
but we are here now
and like i said we'll be doing a q a
and of course the other primary
financial
source of support for us is our sponsors
to whom we are as always grateful we
have two brand new to us sponsors this
week and one almost brand new and
because we're working
um without access screens without any
nuts that i can see
i'm going to be doing the reads this
week but i encourage you brett to jump
in and and ad lib as you see fit all
right i will be reading along in my mind
mind reading well i i guess you would
call it that yes i would confusing as
that might be
okay our first sponsor this week is
brand new to us and we are excited to be
partnering with them it is thesis
thesis makes no tropics no tropics you
know i hope i'm pronouncing that right
no is that no tropics oh maybe i was
pronouncing i i thought the no part was
was wrong no tropics is right oh my god
thesis makes
neutral
i don't think it's new that's the point
it'll make any tropics
okay
this is awesome actually we're really
excited to have them as a sponsor uh
they make something that is spelled
n-o-o-t-r-o-p-i-c-s
i think it's pronounced together i think
that we think it is pronounced no
tropics no tropics are nutrients found
in nature or in the human body that have
been demonstrated to enhance mental
performance in areas such as motivation
creativity mood memory focus and
cognitive processing they work best when
combined with exercise proper nutrition
and mindfulness activities such as for
instance meditation although i feel like
downhill skin would work as well
you're probably already using a notropic
as one of the most commonly consumed is
caffeine but caffeine is far from the
most exciting
effective notropics allow people to
optimize their focus energy and mood
based on the demands of the day in some
cases no tropics can replace the
pharmaceuticals they're usually used to
tackle a problem like adhd
thesis our sponsor for this week our
first sponsor is unusual in the no
tropic market and taking a very
personalized approach they do not assume
that what works for your brother will
work for you for instance or that what
worked for you when you were under
deadline for a dreadful project is going
to work when you are seeking creativity
for a project you've been dreaming about
for years those are different mental
states or different people depending and
you you may be enhanced to be your best
self with different tropics under those
conditions
just as some people become alert after a
cup of coffee and others can fall right
asleep so too do all notropics have
different effects on different people
with the first iteration of thesis
products which is not the ones they're
on now customers were treated like
subjects in a clinical trial with their
full consent blinded customers took a
series of different no tropics blends
over the course of a month and reported
how they felt
analysis of that feedback found that not
surprisingly different people respond
differently to different blends
now after two years 2500 customers and
millions of data points thesis is
confident that they have created a
recommendation algorithm to predict
which blends of no tropics will work
best for any given customer
the process is simple go to their
website take a short quiz and they'll
send a starter kit with four different
blend recommendations to try over the
course of a month
i've tried two of them now and been
intrigued by both the creativity blend
that i'm taking now seems to smooth
things over add a little clarity make
inspiration come a bit easier but of
course the point here is that results
may vary right with fully personalizable
blends there is likely to be a thesis
that is right for you
to get your own customized thesis
starter kit go online to takethesis.com
darkhorse that's t-a-k-e-t-h-e-s-i-s
dot com slash darkhorse take the quiz
and use code darkhorse at checkout for
10 off your first box
yeah i think it's very cool that they uh
basically use a scientific method for
discovering which ones might be relevant
to you not assuming that your mother's
or your brother's druthers will
dictate your own
so yeah it is it is a pretty uh cool
approach yeah indeed
all right our second sponsor this week
is bubs naturals bubs natural sells
three products they're becoming ever
more popular in fitness and outdoor
exploration circles
collagen protein mct oil and apple cider
vinegar gummies there are a lot of
companies already selling these products
but bubs is different here's how
first the products themselves are the
highest quality carefully and
sustainably sourced on which more in a
minute
and bubs is a company with conscience
bubs is named for former navy seal glen
bub doherty who was great friends with
people from all walks of life including
one of the founders of bubs naturals
his friends included ski bums outdoor
enthusiasts hippies seals and everyone
in between
glenn bub doherty stood for
self-improvement and was always helping
others
so for 364 days a year 10 of all profits
go to charities and glen's honor
including the glen doherty foundation
which is dedicated to supporting special
operators and their families as they
transition into civilian life through
scholarships and other professional
training on veterans day 100 of proceeds
go to bubs charity bub's naturals
encapsulates bub's enthusiasm for life
self-improvement and helping others with
this feel great
do good
try for instance bubs naturals collagen
protein which is truly unflavored unlike
many collagen proteins on the market and
soluble unlike some
some on the market it's just got one
ingredient which is critical for joint
and gut health and muscle recovery and
you can add anything glass of water a
smoothie a cup of coffee
and bubs naturals collagen protein is
sustainably sourced from grass-fed and
pasture-raised cows in southern brazil
very far from the amazon if you are
looking for a soluble flavorless protein
to help with for instance post-workout
recovery this could be just the product
for you
with bubs products aim for a motto
another motto that bubs lives by die
young as late as possible
go to bubsnaturals.com and use code
darkhorse at checkout for 20 off your
order
that is actually the perfect way to
describe the ideal senescence profile
right yep die young as late as possible
as late as possible it's not naive it
doesn't imagine
uh that you're going to live forever and
live forever that you will have endless
endless endless youth but die young as
late as possible
all right and our final sponsor this
week is faro life
which makes skin care products from
animal fats primarily lard from pigs
fair life makes a few remarkable skin
products which will probably be unlike
any you have tried before unless you
make your own
using face food for your face and skin
food for the rest of your body
just a tiny bit of face food on my face
evens out the texture and feeling of it
and just feels good
similarly a little bit of skin food on
cracked fingers after too much gardening
or dry legs or elbows after a lot of
dirty work or time in the wind and sun
feels luxurious and again makes your
skins feel smooth and healthy
a little goes a long way it's made in
small batches here in the united states
with no added chemicals or preservatives
and the fat is 100 100 sourced from
farms that use regenerative and
pasture-based animal husbandry which
pharaoh is calling smart lard technology
if you've got sensitive skin or a baby
with a diaper rash or a small child with
eczema or have a very active lifestyle
that includes crafting or wood or metal
working or generally being outside a lot
you should definitely try pharaoh life's
skin food
fair life is a young company the first
lard-based skin care company and is
eager to promote more products utilizing
smart lard technology in the works
include soap deodorant and lip balm
after all the lard works in mysterious
ways
charles mayfield the founder of pharaoh
skin care calls himself a quote healthy
living regenerative farming evangelical
evangelist
he calls himself our pete a healthy
living regenerative farming evangelist
here at darkhurst we love what pharaoh
is doing and we want to see them grow
and provide more consumers access to
healthier skin care options
apply little face food or skin food or
both daily to restore skin health
elasticity moisture and promote
homeostasis dark horse listeners can
save 20 off their first purchase by
going to pharaoh.life
darkhorse or applying the code darkhorse
at checkout
get additional 15 savings by signing up
for a subscription to receive faro skin
food on a monthly bi-monthly or
quarterly basis
that's pharaoh
f-a-r-r-o-w dot life slash darkhorse
all
all
right
um
were we planning to start with ro i
think so yeah i think that's probably
the the right place to start so let us
just first say we are at the 25th
of june
2022
and the supreme court has uh just
overturned roe as was expected based on
the leak from the supreme court um
some
weeks back which we talked about in an
episode dedicated almost entirely to the
leak what it would mean what abortion
meant for people on episode 125 on may
4th which was the week that the leak
came out in an episode that we titled
alito goes a long way alito goes a long
way right you can check that one out so
now it has finally come to pass and i
think there are a number of things that
uh i do not hear being discussed
elsewhere at least not
uh as i think make sense that we should
we should talk about
one has to do with the fact that the
um
the road decision has played a role in
american politics
that
will now change radically and we don't
really know how exactly but i will say
as someone who has been
very interested in the hazard posed to
us by the duopoly
and the need for us to escape
that stranglehold on our politics that
every time somebody comes up with a
mechanism whereby we might escape the
hegemony of the duopoly we are always
threatened with
you can't do that because if you do
attempt to do anything other than elect
one of the uh the main party candidates
what you will do
is you will elect the worst of these
candidates and you will jeopardize row
right and now there's a version of this
on the right as well but the basic point
is because of the importance of row to
both sides there is always this sort of
damocles that hangs over us where we are
not allowed to contemplate any political
future other than
red and blue which is odd because when
people are studied it turns out that the
vast majority of americans are more or
less in agreement on this issue we
talked about this a little bit in our in
our prior episode a fair bit i showed i
showed the responses the results of some
surveys that have been done that show
the vast majority of americans are in
favor of abortion but not uh under all
circumstances up until the moment of
birth yes americans with some
restrictions and we do vary uh in terms
of what those restrictions might be uh
but the vast majority of us are not
extremists on one side or the other yes
more or less
there is a small group that believes
abortion should never ever be
legal and people grow
more uneasy with it the later in
pregnancy
it happens and
um that agreement among most of us is
actually a pretty good match for what
was in the row decision so there's a lot
of people who are uneasy with
the basis of the row decision but
effectively
the road decision
shows exactly this pattern where it did
not allow abortion at any moment in
pregnancy in fact
it was limited by trimester
so we had this decision but it was now
overturned on the basis of um the
underlying legal questions which we
won't get into here
but there is some
um
there is some question now as to what
happens to us politically now that
we have had the appointment of supreme
court justices who were willing to
overturn roe the decision has now been
overturned which kicks this back to the
states the states have now
drawn battle lines where some states are
ratcheting up
their
laws against abortion in some cases very
extreme
restrictions and
other people are
making provisions to provide access to
abortions to people who live in states
that are becoming
more restrictive so now that that is
happening at the state level what does
this do to for example our presidential
politics are we now at liberty to talk
about uh alternatives to the major party
candidates or
is this now going to become a new set of
battle lines where the point is we must
effectively restore roe presumably with
a new decision
my sense
growing up in the
70s 80s but i guess my my more adult
sense of sort of late 80s and 90s
was that
hanging out mostly with democrats as i
did
that we
we understood
that republicans were sort of a
group of different special interests
that didn't naturally have a coalescing
shared set of values that they were the
people who were there for um for
anti-choice there are people there for
2a and and others presumably but those
are the two big ones
and by contrast it was always implied
and sometimes explicit oh well the
democrats have sort of a you know
a platform that makes coherent sense
and
i don't know that to be true that's not
the point of what i'm saying right now
the point of what i'm saying right now
is
somehow
even if that was true back then it seems
increasingly as is really hard to ignore
at least in the last five or ten years
that is certainly descriptive of the
democrats as well
for a while it was uh gay marriage that
was the one thing that democrats were
told you absolutely can't uh
can't leave you leave the fold for but
throughout everything it's been abortion
this has been the issue about which we
are not allowed
to look at any of the other planks in
the platform and say yeah but
actually i disagree with so many of the
other changes you're making over here
what about everything else
so
this is a question i think actually the
dynamics of the two parties changed
radically during the clinton
administration so there was a time prior
to the clinton administration when
for all of its faults the democratic
party was effectively the party of
working people
and it represented their interests
against for example corporate interests
which were naturally at odds
the clinton administration innovated
this change where effectively they
became a second corporate party they
abandoned the
issues that unite working-class people
and in some ways as a mirror of the the
republican party that already existed
what they did is they adopted symbolic
issues in order to drive people to the
polls to to to vote for them right and
you know
it does seem like it changed in the 90s
during the clinton years
it changed in the 90s and you know my
claim
uh which some will take as cynical is
that effectively you have two parties
that are involved in influence peddling
two parties that have a business model
and their business model involves
winning enough votes to have power and
then monetizing that power by selling it
to special interests right and the fact
is working people are not a special
interest in the same sense that let's
say the fossil fuel industry is a
special interest
so now that we have two of these parties
these issues that are used to divide us
are also used to motivate us and the key
thing to understand is that the parties
do not inherently need large numbers of
people right what they need to do is win
you can win with a very small fraction
of the electorate mostly electric can be
tuned out and you can
still win the same amount of power and
then you can monetize it in the same way
so in some sense the parties don't care
that they're turning us off what they
care about is
winning enough power to uh to distribute
to their actual constituents who are
these uh these moneyed interests
but nonetheless we are this week now
facing a new landscape that i don't
think any of us understand well yet
we've lived under the sword of damocles
for so long that it isn't clear whether
we will just see you know a change in
the narrative and we will see the same
motivation or whether this will remove
some of the motivation from one side or
the other
right
i would argue that in some sense that
this likely uh
you know is
harmful to
well i see you know it's on both sides
it's harmful to
the republicans the motivation to get
people to the polls to over overturn
this uh this decision which is viewed as
um as essentially evil on on the one
side um that uh is eliminated because
now they've crossed the finish line uh
on that goal
um but it can be used uh to suggest that
it's even more important uh that we get
no more appointees that look like the
last
boy what is it for i guess
i may have that number wrong to the
supreme court right and there you know
there was
i think absurd talk about packing the
court prior to the most recent election
it may be that this kick starts uh that
discussion
um
but there was another aspect i wanted to
raise there's something that haunts the
discussion of rho and i almost never
hear it discussed especially on the left
and when it is discussed on the right it
is discussed in terms that make it uh
inaccessible and that has to do with the
question of
what is upstream of the right or lack
thereof to
an abortion and that is the question of
how we are all to behave sexually right
within
this
debate
is the question about where is it that
one's control over whether or not to
produce a child is correctly exercised
and the right
tends to lean in the direction
effectively of
a more restrictive sexual environment is
the place to control whether you get
pregnant and in fact in our last
discussion we talked about the fact that
their position was incoherent if they
are not also supportive of the right to
an abortion in the case of rape or
incest
right because if you have that right
then the point is
there is a control that can be exerted
um
at the level of deciding who sleeps with
whom
but if we don't allow people to access
this right even when they've been raped
then obviously that that's uh it's
self-inconsistent
but
so the the question is we've got two
sides of this debate the left the
democrats
effectively portray
the question of
sex and who has sex with whom as
entirely an individual decision and
certainly many of us have some sympathy
with that position on the other hand
is it really just a personal decision in
other words
it has some implication for
for example the spreading of sexually
transmitted diseases it has some
implication for
the
coherence of our societal environment
over the presence of
two parents in a household
and so
really i think there's a hidden debate
here which is what
what do we collectively believe about um
sexual liberty what is the right
position and the left seems to favor
uh a
uh free-for-all
and the right seems to favor a
reactionary position one that in some
sense is uh
maybe appropriate to a pre-birth control
environment and nowhere do i see
a
a constituency that is balancing these
two things and recognizing that a
free-for-all actually has all kinds of
negative
implications uh whereas a reactionary
environment makes no sense uh with birth
control freely available
well there's a lot there i mean i'm not
i'm not sure that i want to soliloquy
back at you i think maybe this would be
better done if we can exchange things a
bit a bit more uh dynamically but um two
things that i remember right off the bat
in terms of how i want to respond are
your framing
which i think is accurate although i
think many people on both sides would
disagree with it
reveals that
in on this issue the people on the left
as it were the people who are um
who are pro-choice
um at least the extremist pro-choice
people are really arguing for a highly
individualist
set of policies a set of policies which
is driven by individual needs and the
people on the right the people who are
anti-choice
are in fact arguing for a collectivist
position which of course is the exact
opposite of what we usually think of
when we think of of left versus right
you know left tends to be the
collectivist position and right tends to
be the individualist position and what
we have here is is the inverse so that's
that's intriguing on its own
and then i think there's a lot more to
be explored
with regard to
what i think was your final point here
around the you know the reactionary
move on the right to
the the social impact of of obliterating
the right to abortion which of course
the overturning of rugby weight has not
obliterated the right to abortion but
has obliterated the federally
um
protect protected thank you um right to
abortion no matter where you are in the
united states
um
fat
is generally framed by people on the
right in terms and with a clear ethos
that is frankly not just reactionary but
regressive
uh traditionalist
sexist misogynistic
and
uh that in part is you know the fact
that that is true is part of why and
certainly not all of why but part of why
many women reject the argument out of
hand because they see in it that there
is also wrapped up in it
a desire to maintain a sort of like
genesis-driven um understanding of what
women are as if we are you know coming
from you know a thrown out piece of
of the original man which in the 21st
century in most the 20th century most
people were coming to understand that
this is not in fact the case
and both birth control
and
safe and legal abortion do provide an
a freeing an empowerment such that uh
women are able to have more agency with
regard to what we choose to do with our
lives but
but
we never hear on the left those people
we almost never i i feel like i've heard
little glimmers of this but we almost
never hear
the other the other question which is
what effects do does this have on
society which is the question that you
are raising here and in part sorry
before before you respond to that in
part because it's been
i'm coming up with all the wrong words
has been criminalized it's been it's
been sort of demonized the very
conversation has been demonized because
the only people who've been having it
are on the right have a very hard um
hardcore stance against abortion under
any circumstances and so if you ever
even raise the question of
let's just talk about what the effect
of
uh of abortion is going to be on society
you get labeled as right-wing even if
you very much are not
yeah
there is no
room in the conversation and maybe
maybe this is obvious but
it's like
there is a telltale sign of a
conversation
that has been so embedded in a political
environment that um it's
dysfunctional
by its very nature and that telltale
sign
is that any
step in the direction of nuance is
punished right right and you know i i
must say and you know you have said this
on your sub stack caitlyn flanagan has
said something like this was it in the
atlantic
but
there is something
almost frightening about the
um
the inability to escape a dynamic where
you are either effectively enthusiastic
about abortion or you can't even
contemplate it for you know a
barely implanted um
zygote
uh that is the product of rape and the
problem is this strands all of us or
almost all of us right in a conversation
that we can't even have right do i want
government as a manifestation of our
collective will
telling you you know
who you're allowed to sleep with of
course not on the other hand
i think anybody would have to look at
the sexual environment that we have and
say you know it's a fairly decent test
of what happens when you just basically
suspend all the rules and the answer is
it's not good for people it doesn't make
them sexually satisfied among other
things it's a complete failure in that
regard
what's more it results in us uh
sexualizing very young girls which
doesn't give them the opportunity to
move into the world and be serious about
other things because it does instantiate
this you know your sexual value is your
value as the the primary uh driving
force so it's a very unhealthy
environment and all of the tools that
you might use to fix it are forbidden
because they're taken to be a political
sin in an environment where abortion is
understood as the singular issue in
which you have to have
an extreme position yeah
do you have that picture i sent you
zack this is going to seem like a
non-sequitur
no it seems like a lemur this is a lamer
for those for those listening not
watching this is an individual barisia
variogata ruffed lemur
individuals of this species i don't
think it was the subspecies but of this
species lived on the island nosy mangaby
where just off the coast of madagascar
where i did my dissertation research
and there this was in the late 90s i was
told by a local man and naturalist that
a particular plant whose identity i've
long since forgotten
was eaten by verisia very god it was
eaten by individual females of this
species of lemur as an abortifacient
now i don't know if this is true i've
never seen i don't see it in the
literature
uh
he assured me and i asked another
naturalist and he said yeah i've heard
that too but i have no idea if that's
one or two data points i don't know from
from once it originally comes
um but
the idea that apropos nothing we weren't
talking you know i wasn't talking in my
very poor french and his pretty middling
french neither of us in our first
languages while walking around the
rainforest in madagascar about
reproductive rights you know we just we
ran into a troop with these guys
and he mentioned that there was this
this plant that the females ate
as a way to terminate their pregnancies
when they needed to
um
whether or not that particular thing is
true
it got me thinking then and has me
thinking again now
about
the fact that it shouldn't surprise us
if this
um and other smart animals find ways to
solve their own problems and
there are a lot of reasons that a woman
or a rough lemur might feel the need to
terminate a pregnancy
this issue has never simply been
as simple as it's a life which is what
we are told which is what you know what
the the sort of the tagline
for the position of the extremist on the
right is it's a life
for some people that is the issue
beginning middle end that's all you have
to say that's all there is to consider
but for most of us
it's it's not there's just more to it
and the fact of there being um
two
organisms involved a pregnant female in
this case of a libra or a
pregnant adult human female in the case
of uh women
doesn't
that and and a fetus
does not acknowledge i mean it does not
it's not responsive the argument that
it's a life is not responsive to
actually what about the other life
you're talking about here
and again i don't know if actually
other organisms are using plants and
supportive patients it wouldn't surprise
me i've been told it's true i can't find
evidence in literature but of course the
organisms aren't going out and putting
stuff into the scientific literature are
they
so
i i guess i wanted to add this in a
couple of other little pieces in here
about how really complex and messy
categories are
how simple some of them are
things like
female
very simple
but at the point of whether or not women
should have a right to terminate a
pregnancy that if they carried it
through to term
would radically alter everything that
they could do with their own lives and
would likely mean a much poorer quality
of life for that child
to respond to that with it's a life we
can't have this conversation
has always felt like it is missing the
point missing the point and you know i
think your
allusion to
the recent
debate over
defining
what a woman is for example is exactly
right this throws you and me for a loop
because the answer is well
this is a biological question
right it has a
you know 500 million year history at the
very least
and so
you know the necessary tools to even
have the discussion are not limited to
this moment in history in this
particular species they are embedded in
a much bigger story that has a lot of
logical rungs on the ladder and this one
is the same way right the fact is even
birth
is a bit arbitrary right a human
baby is not independent even if we say
it's viable because it can survive at
this moment survive means with the
intense care of adults right and
very few people right a vanishingly tiny
number would be comfortable in a society
that has as much abundance as we have
with people terminating their already
born children because their economic
circumstances have changed so the point
is we already draw a line in which the
point is we say actually you have to
care for this individual beyond this
point or you have to you know at least
make sure that they are cared for right
so
so i mean
this is a point that we made in episode
125 as well and that i make in the
abortion essay that i wrote for ariel a
few years back
um but there you know there are two
lines
which
can be understood as arbitrary as the
lines on which policy is made but
they're not arbitrary in one way right
and those two lines which are conception
and birth
are both real
and also for apparently the vast
majority of americans at least who are
the people who whose survey answers we
have access to
uh for the vast majority of us we don't
see either of those lines as the lines
that should be our the arbiter of of
what should be possible right conception
is a real moment and birth is a real
moment and most americans anyway and i
posit probably an even greater majority
of of other human beings beings
worldwide don't view either conception
or birth as the line before or after
which abortion should be um
accepted right the lines are not
arbitrary in the sense that we can
define a
relatively precise moment they are
arbitrary with respect uh well at least
birth is arbitrary with respect to
development
but you know all of the
with the exception of people who truly
believe that each
uh offspring is preordained by an
intentional god right people who believe
that
uh are at least logically consistent to
treat uh a zygote similarly to the way
they treat a baby because the point is
the intent uh is a baby in somebody's
mind but for those of us who don't
believe that these are
all individually planned and preordained
the point is both of these arguments
fall apart as you push them to the
extremes which means that we really are
naturally
in this middle ground which you know
it's not where you want to be because it
does involve drawing an arbitrary
boundary um but
you know this is more or less without
the political dynamic this is where
people end up right they end up
increasingly uneasy the closer you get
to birth and most people would draw a
line at birth that they wouldn't uh
contemplate crossing
except in maybe very extreme
circumstances
but
uh i i don't know i mean i i guess
i would
i wish we were having the conversation
about what our society should look like
and you know what the rules of
interaction
um should be you know my my position is
that uh
sex is a very important thing and
therefore a society that treats it
uh in a profane way is not a healthy
society because it takes something
extremely precious and powerful
and um
you know
renders it
uh economic or frivolous or
or whatever you know it's not mine to
say for anyone else but i guess the
point is i think there even if you're
just a utilitarian there's a question
about whether or not
a free-for-all
is actually net better from the point of
whatever it is that you value from a
system that has some kinds of rules or
guidance about how you interact and
therefore would treat this issue quite
differently yeah
rules uh
to which are not attached draconian
measures such as we find in
some countries still
to this day
but expectations around
behavior
that individuals of both sexes
can
abide by in a way that feels fulfilling
to them and not just not just the fringe
not not expectations that obviously
benefit one sex over the other
um and and keep one keep one subservient
but
there must there must be a way and this
is wholly consistent with our you know
our themes in almost every regard and
the themes in our book as well you know
we can't go back
um both because we can't go back we've
just we've gone too far there have been
too many technological and other
advances nor should we want to go back
because back wasn't all that good for
nearly as many people
so we must go forward but we must not go
forward we should not want to go forward
in many of the ways that we are now
being told by the so-called left the
so-called progressives uh in which you
throw over reality in favor of
what giving everyone a cookie and a star
you know it's it's it's infantilizing
it's reality denying and it makes no
sense and the two options are not
infantilizing reality denying nonsense
or regressive misogynistic
um
you know
lifestyles and i'm losing the last word
there but you know those those can't be
the two options that's that's not what
we're actually arguing about and just to
go i guess maybe full circle
those are the two options that we would
that the two major parties at this point
and it really did feel at least to me in
the 70s 80s 90s like this was mostly
coming from the republicans but at this
point for sure
both of the parties are interested in
having us believe that those are the two
options
pick your hell really and
you know each side will tell their
version of what looks like held to the
vast majority of us in the middle as a
sort of a paradise as a utopia but the
fact is
um that that most versions of the
traditionalist misogynistic lifestyles
would be hell for most people
and most versions of the reality denying
infantilizing nonsense
that the modern left is encouraging
would be hell for most people and for
the rest of us we
we are fighting for an ability to create
a world that actually makes some sense
and that recognizes reality and that
maximizes the chance that that
everyone can experience an ability to to
flourish
and um maybe
maybe this is a strange segue and you
didn't know i wanted to say this today
but i did want to
tell a brief anecdote from from my own
family
because in the wake of both me
publishing on
on abortion in ariel i think in 2019 it
was so i think three years ago and in
the wake of our talking about this issue
in early may about two months ago
we got a lot of very good
a lot of very good responses but i also
got uh some pushback from what i view as
extremists on on one side um i killed a
got called a baby killer right
and
i'm you know i'm very clear in the
aerial piece
that while i have never had to make the
choice i was never in a position i was
some combination
of
skillful and lucky enough never to have
been in a position to have made a choice
but i am good friends with with people
who have
and
what i haven't said publicly and i have
asked him if i may talk about this and
he has said yes
is that my beloved younger brother is
adopted
and when we when we
talk to each other we don't refer to him
as my adopted brother and i don't
usually introduce him you know in in
absentia to people as my adopted brother
although sometimes it's relevant
but he's my brother he was adopted he
was he was born to a teenage mother
somewhere in the middle of the country
who loved their daughter and who loved
their daughter sufficiently and had
means sufficient
and had values consistent
with
having her take the baby to term but
then immediately give that child up for
adoption
she had been in a relationship with
a dude
some years older than her you know
classic story right like very good girl
in a good family who got impregnated by
a guy who had no business anywhere near
her
and the family
didn't believe in abortion
and she carried to term
and my parents adopted my brother
uh
within a day or two of his birth
and brought him home and
he was my brother from from then on
and i have i have always and my brother
has always been grateful uh that that
family
made the decision that they did and that
they and that
that i have a brother right and that
that he has the family that he has
he like me is pro-choice and he always
has been and this is not inconsistency
this doesn't say anything about him
wishing that he didn't exist him wishing
that he himself
had been aborted which would have been
an easier choice at some level for that
young 15 or 16 year old back in the back
in the early 70s just you know slightly
after row was even even um made it
possible
um
we can be grateful for that particular
choice that was made and also grateful
that it was a choice
grateful for the human being that exists
and is my brother and is my children's
uncle
and
also grateful that
that girl as have generations of girls
since then had the option to have
safe and legal abortions should they so
choose this is not an inconsistency
and i guess i guess that's it at this
point i will just keep repeating the
same thing but it's not
i think people want to trot out examples
like beethoven would have been aborted
right if right right but you you can't
do this we have to have an adult
conversation and the adult conversation
does not involve us uh breaking down
into a puddle of sorrow for all of the
sperm that might have met an egg that
would have been someone great that would
have changed the world right that's not
how it works right the fact is
people come into being
circumstances affect them they become
what they are and
looking back at an individual life and
saying well what if a different choice
had been made is it's sleight of hand
right
i i think i think it is i'm not sure i'm
not sure i could defend that though i
think you're right i think you're right
it feels like sleight of hand it feels
like there's no obligation to say any of
this which is part of why i haven't said
it before all right it's sleight of hand
because
the number of people who might have been
but for all sorts of things right
including just sperm barely having
missed egg or
you know having been a fraction of a
second later to an egg than some other
sperm
the point is do you want to do all those
calculations about what might have been
you know your your brain will hang up at
the sheer
complexity of the calculation it does
not result in a coherent understanding
of an alternative world or do you want
to be selective and say oh would you
have that person not exist
right it just it's one or the other
either you want to understand everything
that might have been in which case
you're going to be
reduced to ignoring this by virtue of
the fact that what you take to be
important will be lost in a sea of other
things that might be equally important
or more so right or you want to say
those who are here are a different
matter than the thing that resulted in
them being here right
you know do you want you know if
somebody missed the bus and didn't get
to a date that would have resulted in an
important person having been born who we
will never even know of because the date
didn't occur right like that's not a
tragedy right it may in fact be a major
loss to humanity that a person didn't
come into being as a result of a missed
bus but there's no way there's no way to
calculate it honorably right yeah well
and i think
this is actually another example of
the rise of the import of calculation
and quantitative analysis of human
experience
uh over actually recognizing how diverse
and complex
we are right like okay you know can you
calculate that uh well then let's and
let's ignore all of the things that we
can't calculate let's ignore the
the qualifiable and focus only on the
quantifiable and yeah probably also put
our biases in there because once we you
know fill the quantifiable with enough
black boxes it looks
it becomes hard for anyone else to come
in and figure out what's been done
and once there are
once there is a thing to be counted
it's easier to point to that and say
that thing is precious than to say oh
there was never a thing therefore of
course there was no precious
preciousness there to begin with yeah i
mean it's really it's another version of
owning the downsides of your own
arguments right if we're going to look
at somebody who does exist and say they
might not have the point is that same
calculation results in all sorts of
people who didn't exist but for a
thousand a thousand things so
um you know
it's cheating at one level
uh to drag that in i would also say this
is a question about which kinds of
calculations you want to do yeah right a
simple calculation about you know you do
or you don't have this right and it's
absolute or it isn't is absurd
the fact is trying to maximize anything
is devastating in any complex system and
so trying to maximize or minimize this
right is a problem and there's a reason
that other parts of the world don't
typically do that there are some that do
but you know europe for example has you
know they've found a balance point in
general um and it's widely variable i
mean you know the different nation
states in europe have different numbers
uh different numbers of weeks usually um
before and after which abortion is legal
um after which sometimes it might be
legal in the case of saving the mother's
life for instance um but you know and
some some of
some of the countries uh that we in
america who are pro-choice have
historically like to trot out as
evidence of
being you know have full having full
reproductive rights
actually have fairly restrictive numbers
you know some of these are at the end of
the first trimester or earlier
which is well before a lot of genetic
testing can happen and you know it feels
it that would that would be
a restrictive step back
for the majority of americans who live
in states where the state law is still
protecting abortion at the
at more or less the same level as it did
a few days ago yeah um now i do think it
belongs somewhere in this conversation
there is certainly talk in states that
are eager to uh obliterate this right
there is talk about preventing people
from example for example of crossing a
state boundary to seek an abortion
which
i would be shocked if such provisions
stood up to a challenge in the court
because of course you have a
constitutional right to move between
states and so in any case i do think we
are headed towards a world in which
there will be differential access in
different states which uh
is one reason that a federal
policy might
find itself on
more solid legal ground right equal
protection might involve uh people in
all states having equal rights to
procedures like this i don't know but
that is at least discussed as one
possible basis for replacement for
for row but where we are headed short of
something like a federal provision that
did protect us as a matter of equal
protection under the law
we are headed for a world in which it is
vastly more inconvenient in some for
people living in some states than others
which you know
does seem unfair it does seem unfair
and
it is also there's also been
wildly
unequal access for a while now even with
rose standing
that's true
that that doesn't that doesn't make it
okay that does not make it okay
but that
yeah we will see what happens next
obviously uh it's not it's not
heartening it felt it felt like a very
sad day
it also was uh we all knew it was coming
and
uh and as we said in episode 125
there are legal scholars on both sides
of this issue who really feel very
strongly for instance uh that we may not
have the right to choose who feel that
rho was bad law yeah well it'll be very
interesting uh to see where we go i do
hope that one thing that comes out of it
is that we have a
more nuanced conversation about
you know what
what sex ought to be with respect to how
we understand each other and i hope that
we move in the direction of taking it
much more seriously and and honoring it
rather than
trivializing it
i guess i would also
um
this is more at home
a while back in the conversation but
i also think that in that discussion
we really increasingly need to
draw a distinction between
collaborative sex and antagonistic sex
and realize that what we are doing that
the free-for-all has actually moved us
in the direction of a mode of sex where
there is no intent you know men have no
intent to invest at all in the people
with whom they are having sex that that
cannot help but echo
what in the past would have been an
antagonistic version of sex the idea of
impregnating somebody and walking away
it's not a kind thing right it's not
something a decent person should want to
do and the fact that we are now
pretending that this is a commonplace uh
behavior and that we should all want
this men and women should uh want to be
having sex and not thinking about
commitment it you know a it's not clear
that that makes anybody happier or more
satisfied and b it's not clear that we
should want a society in which that's
the way people behave well it is as we
have said elsewhere including in our
book at some length um it is
uh upholding men at their worst as the
ideal to which we should all aspire yeah
as if men at their worst should be the
ideal to which any of us should aspire
you know women at their worst similarly
it's just
this happens to be a man at their worst
thing
and and women and you know good men or
men who would only very occasionally
consider going to their worst mode are
all like okay well it's um
it's a free-for-all so i guess let's do
this
uh and it doesn't it doesn't leave
people
um joyous satisfied sexually or
otherwise um or in good shape with
regard to the rest of their lives yeah
um
i wanted to talk about um
bacteria really i'm not sure that it
really fits in here anymore
um
let me just let me just very very
briefly i can't i can't i had it all
sort of worked in and i think we kind of
kind of
flew by wherever i thought it was going
to go but before we before we segue into
twitter sanctioned violence
um i guess i guess the point here is i
guess why i thought it belonged here is
life is weird and
as biologists well know but many people
outside of biology including other
scientists often don't recognize
the categories often have fuzzy
boundaries and some you know some again
some categories don't female and male
not fuzzy intersex fine
that refers to the binary of female
versus male but many categories do have
fuzzy boundaries
and evolution often finds a way and
simple rubrics are often too simplistic
um rather than sophisticated so
as it turns out i can't show my screen
here
so i will link in the show notes
this uh
article published this week in science
uh the largest bacterium ever found
which is surprisingly complex it's
bigger than drosophila it's bigger than
the fruit fly that is the um
the model organism that's used in so
much genetics research and other
development developmental biology
research as well
so from the lay summary rather than the
actual like the slightly more through
wait can i can i raise one issue yeah
okay as a biologist hearing that there
is a bacterium bigger than a drosophila
did you say that yeah so i'm not going
to be able to show it but actually but
here's the problem so there's got to be
some biological answer to it you're
gonna it's it's good all right so here
i'm just gonna tell the audience what it
is that has to be addressed by whatever
it is you're about to tell me
the problem is that cells have a limit
on their size now bacteria are much
smaller than eukaryotic cells so i guess
their limit in size is presumably not
governed by this unless the point is
that the transport mechanism for oxygen
into the cell
is less effective and therefore
the
ability of oxygen to make it into the
cell is greater so the question is how
does a very large bacterium get enough
oxygen into the interior of its cell
given that its surface area per unit of
volume drops the bigger the cell is how
can it possibly exist
so i've sent you a relevant picture zach
which is just a screenshot from one of
the tables in the paper
which uh that's great that's actually
not even the main
intriguing thing i think about this
research but as you will see once
hopefully this comes through
um
this image from the paper that was just
published this week in science
reveals that while this bacterium is
indeed uh longer than a fruit fly um in
fact longer than a centimeter oh it's
like a pine needle it's super long and
then wow well see
there you go biology works you can see
that it would have to be something like
that yeah
so uh so zag is still working on the on
the visual for that when that comes up
it'll come up it'll be clear what we're
just talking about but here from the
late summary quote we usually think of
bacteria as microscopic isolated cells
or colonies
sampling a mangrove swamp voland at all
found an unusually large sulfur
oxidizing bacterium with a complex
membrane organization and predicted life
cycle
using a range of microscopy techniques
the authors observed highly polyploid
cells with dna and ribosomes
compartmentalized within membranes
single cells of the bacterium dubbed
canditatus theo margarita magnifica
although thin and tubular stretched more
than a centimeter in length ah so um
that that's all
fine and interesting and i love that you
just did that live like how is it
possibly going to work you're going to
need to you have the oxygen get in
um so just to make it clear how this
solves that problem
the
center of this long hair like bacterium
is never far from the surface so the
diffusion problem is solved by the
proximity of all of the
cytoplasm to the surface of the
bacterium
and i'm reminded of course as all of our
listeners and viewers will will
recognize immediately of plethodonics
of course of course plethodontids are a
um a clade of salamanders actually the
largest clade of salamanders uh and they
are lungless all of them in in the clade
and being lungless they need to
get their oxygen into their bodies some
other ways they're also fully
terrestrial as adults so they haven't
retained gills as some of the
pedomorphic species of salamanders have
but what they have is like all
amphibians cutaneous respiration which
is to say they can breathe through their
skin
and as such what you would predict for
all plethodonins for all of this clade
of lungless salamanders is that they are
weight for it long and thin they're
going to have a high surface area to
volume ratio just like this new giant
bacterium does
and
any time you don't have some additional
way to basically pump oxygen into the
bot or do gas exchange
via an active mechanism such as most
vertebrates have with lungs
you will you expect to have either a
different solution
you know gills and water where where the
oxygen is being pulled out of water
or
or a solution that has been happened
upon a number of times increase the
surface area to volume ratio
by uh making yourself long at them okay
um the really the reason my screen has
died um the reason this came up for me
here in particular may be of you know we
maybe just deep down a rabbit hole here
but one of the ways that this bacterium
pulls it off is that it has
uh let's see and i don't have the paper
pulled up because i can't show it but
if memory serves
yes there are and this is just
the last the last phrase in the actual
abstract of the paper
compartmentalization of genomic material
and ribosomes in translationally active
organelles bound by bioenergetic
membranes
indicate gain of complexity in the theo
margarita lineage and challenge
traditional concept of bacterial cells
so to translate that
bacteria are what are called prokaryotes
they don't have their genetic material
encased within a nuclear membrane they
don't have a cell nucleus
and so what you have
boy
two to three i can't remember one to two
two billion years ago a long time ago is
the evolution of eukaryotes
which is to say the origin of the cell
nucleus and the encasing of the genomic
material of the dna uh within that
nucleus and so bacteria it's all it's
it's
they're simple they're understood to be
simple and there's no
compartmentalization and so the
organelles and the and the dna are all
just kind of free-floating well not so
this bacterium so this is not a eukarya
this is a different evolution of
compartmentalization of genetic material
but within what is clearly a bacterium
and not within a eukaryotic lineage
and you know this may this may well hold
no interest at all for many people but
for me this just this reminds me
precisely of
how our categories can be real and
accurate and we can say okay we know
what prokaryotes are and we know what
eukaryotes are and what those things are
actually describing is lineages
and we've got eukaryotes with
compartmentalization of dna and that
starts to be what we think of when we
think of eukaryotes well are there
bacteria are still around
it's like crocodiles like crocodiles
evolved a long time ago and they haven't
changed much it must be working for them
right there's a lot going on with a lot
of bacteria it's a good design that it
can compete with more modern designs
exactly they're just they're sticking
with what they've got unlike you know
humans who've been changing rapidly for
a very long time well bacteria is a
giant clade it's an ancient clade it's
more ancient than anything that's
eukaryotic again that has
its dna sequestered but then a nucleus
in in its cells
and yet even so there are some bacteria
that have
solved the solution of how to segregate
it's how to compartmentalize its its
working parts uh be a different but very
similar method yeah so
another way to say that is that
the stories that we tell ourselves when
we do a good job of synthesis the
stories that we tell ourselves are true
and we can tell because when
a
lineage violates what we think to be a
rule it violates it in ways that are
familiar because it's solving the same
problem that its ancestor which became a
eukaryote
also solved so that's that's uh
fascinating yeah okay so i hope you
learned more about this this is a it's
still brand new um there's a lot not a
lot a lot not known and of course it
raises the question of why why this
bacterium in these mangroves um is doing
this compartmentalization of a bunch of
important stuff when most bacteria
aren't
and why something yeah that is a
fascinating question and why uh
some eukaryote that had this trick on
board by virtue of being a eukaryote
isn't in that niche yeah yeah
very interesting right okay obviously
it's time to um to talk about twitter
yeah of course
all right so um let me
set this up
a friend of ours
dr rollergator who had an extremely
popular
ironic account in which he uh often said
very important things but did so in a uh
a highly stylized fashion that often
involved him shouting in all caps
uh was he is a real person yes he is
well sure he's not a bot or a crocodile
or crocodilian um
he was suspended
four months ago
for
um advocating violence on twitter and
what he had in fact said i'm not sure if
zach is in a position to show
dr rollergator's tweet if not i can just
describe it well you sent me something
well don't worry about it i'll describe
it
um what dr roller gator said i believe
he was talking to jordan peterson and
uh
justin trudeau
who uh peterson had taken trudeau to
task and dr rollergator
suggested that i believe this is right
that they purchase
white leather gloves with which to slap
each other across the face
signaling the desire for
a duel
and
this is odd because
twitter suspended dr relegator and for
four months has
what presumably is just simply ignored
appeals that this was not in fact
inciting violence
and um it's
obviously
you know if you think about it
on the one hand while it may technically
be true
that um
slapping somebody across the face with a
white leather glove is violence by some
legal definition no no
i don't think so yeah well but i'm not a
legal scholar it sounds like you
plausibly be assault but violence
seriously right but
here's the point one a slap is
obviously symbolic at one level right an
open hand distributes the force over a
large surface area so while slap may not
feel good the point is it is not
inherently designed to do damage but a
slap with a glove is yet one more step
removed from from violence it is
symbolic and then dr rollergator's tweet
is yet a third step removed in the sense
that he was speaking ironically and was
clearly not advocating that anybody
actually slapped anybody else so the
idea of being suspended
for tweeting such a thing which is still
believing presumably that some people
might deserve it
deserve it or not
the point is
do we really want twitter
um
policing the question of violence if it
views this as uh sufficiently violent
that it is uh justification to spend an
account uh indefinitely well this takes
a whole new turn
uh with the overturning of roe v wade in
which many people including quite a
number of blue check marks have
advocated outright violence on twitter
and not suffered the same fate as dr
rollergater i've seen
tweets that advocate
uh burning down churches the building of
pipe bombs all sorts of things right now
that's actual
violence being advocated by people on
twitter and twitter is doing nothing
about it
so
there's an obvious conflict here there's
a question about uh the application of
the
the rule so twitter ostensibly has a
rule against advocating
violence but what could possibly explain
dr rolegator's account being suspended
for advocating that someone buy leather
gloves with which to slap someone else
across the face when people who are
advocating the burning downer churches
or the building of pipe bombs uh are
allowed to continue on with this
behavior
so i want to give you a chance to jump
in if you had anything no i mean this is
i mean i think is when we were talking
about this earlier as you said this is
one for me and two for you
territory right it's uh
and as i've said a number of times it's
twitter sanctioned violence
right and so this is really the key
point is that on the one hand so what we
have is selective enforcement right we
have a circumstance in which certain
people because uh twitter views them as
politically hostile uh have have a such
a low bar set that you can't even make
an ironic tweet about a a white leather
glove and not be suspended but for other
people apparently there's no level of
violence that you could advocate that uh
would get you in similar trouble and the
point i wanted to make is
this is not twitter being against
violence right this is actually
characteristic of something else
entirely when somebody wants their
opponent
restrained so that they cannot engage in
violence but they want full liberty to
engage in violence that's not an
anti-violence position that's actually a
pro-violence position and a
violent asymmetry that is being
advocated and so i think increasingly we
need to look at what twitter is doing in
this light and you know twitter is of
course not alone we've seen this on all
of the social media platforms the idea
that there is some
set of rules in the terms of service
that is understood to apply to everybody
but the differential application of
those rules is actually
nakedly political or
it's political but for a thin veneer you
know a pretense of fair application and
at what point do we watch these things
being unfairly applied at what point do
we just simply get to say i'm sorry in
terms of service that applies to some
users and not others is not the terms of
service right it's a weapon of some kind
and
i think that's just simply where we are
with twitter we are watching them
wield weapons against people who hold
perspectives different than their own
and who needs a social media platform
that is willing to let you say whatever
you want so long as you agree with them
yeah
not i
yeah but it's what we've got but it's
what we've got it's what we've got and
uh anyway it's um
it is ironically exactly the thing that
leads to violence
right if you if you want a less violent
world the world
you know i think actually
um sam harris has made this point right
we have two choices we can either learn
how to talk
or we can resort to violence because
we're left with nothing else so we
better figure out how to talk and if the
places on which we would talk or the
paper on which we would write to each
other are going to take a position that
certain things can't be discussed well
you know they are setting the stage for
a violent future that
all of us will regret
is absolutely true
um you suggested at the top of the hour
that all of our three main topics linked
together
in the transition between them it's not
obviously apparent to me so we talked
about row and various issues around
around abortion rights when i talked
about twitter sanctioned violence and
next up
we have the cdc
admitting something about what they've
actually been doing or rather failing to
do which they said they had been doing
all along
with regard to tracking adverse events
associated with uh kova jacksons yeah so
what we have here is a rather shocking
revelation
the result of a freedom of information
act request
filed by children's health defense
with the cdc and what they asked
unfortunately we can't show it to you
because of our uh technical issues here
you want to show the top page go forward
of the pdf
i don't know what you've got there
you've got the cdc pdf from
january or february of 2021.
yep
ah so okay
what we have here i believe if i'm
seeing it correctly
is a document
from the cdc in which they discuss in
early 2021 how they are going to analyze
evidence of adverse events in order to
discover whether or not
the new clovid19 vaccines are creating
health problems
that are worthy of
some sort of regulatory change and what
they describe
is a regime i believe it is section
2.3 of this document
they
outline a mechanism
i would argue and our good friend
matthew crawford has also argued that it
is a very flawed mechanism for analyzing
the data in the vares system but what
they advocate is a system
the acronym is
prr
and effectively it involves looking at
the ratio of different
adverse events between vaccines so you
take a new vaccine like the covet
vaccine
the covet mrna vaccine and you compare
it to a long-standing vaccine and you
see whether the ratio of adverse events
that are reported differs from the prior
vaccine and if it does differ that might
suggest if there's an elevated level of
one particular kind of adverse event it
might suggest
uh that
something is a mess let me just quote
from that document that zach just had up
the relevant portion which you've just
done a very good job of summarizing but
let's just have it
in the cdc's words this is from
uh the
briefing document posted on the cdc
website in january 2021
updated in february 2022 with minor
changes section
2.3.1 proportional reporting ratio prr
cdc will perform prr data mining on a
weekly basis or as needed prrs compare
the proportion of a specific ae that is
adverse event following a specific
vaccine versus the proportion of the
same ae following receipt of another
vaccine
a safety signal is defined as a prr of
at least two chi-squared statistic of at
least four and three or more cases of
the ae following receipt of the specific
vaccine of interest
i sped up because
none of the none of the particulars
matters here it's the first sentence
cdc will perform prr data mining on a
weekly basis or as needed and then the
next the final little paragraph here cdc
will apply appropriate comparative
vaccines eg adjuvanted vaccines like
shrinrix and or fluid for adjuvanted
cobot 19 vaccines and adjust for
severity and age distributions where
applicable
and the
the the first punch line here which i
have in front of me i don't know maybe
you want to do it or i can just go for
it arrive at it
um is that i'm reading right now from a
piece written by josh gutzkow phd on
uh the defender blog on children's
health defense who uh says you know i
was concerned about what we're gonna
find with adverse events but at least
the cdc said repeatedly we're going to
be doing this prr
these you know by which we could tell
and you know there are problems itself
with prr as a mechanism yeah for example
if you have two vaccines that have a
high rate of adverse events but the same
ratio of harms it will be not detectable
by this method right so if a particular
adjuvant for example created a given
ratio of arms
and the ratio was therefore the same
between two different vaccines that use
that same adjuvant you wouldn't see it
by this mechanism so the mechanism
leaves
many routes by which it would fail to
detect adverse events that matter but it
turns out that's not even the problem
here right the problem here is worse
than that
we got a dog i have sorry guys
um a dog trapped by equipment yeah so
there are
more obvious and better
ways to assess whether or not you've got
an adverse event associated with a
vaccine the advantage of prr apparently
is that it's simple
uh there's uh there's a rubric already
in process it takes basically a push of
a button uh it really it really takes
almost nothing to do it and
what i just read from the document that
was first put up by the cdc in january
21 and updated with maya changes in
february 22
said quote cdc will perform prr data
mani
cdc will perform prr data mining on a
weekly basis or as needed
and yet
when uh
the
children's health defense put in a foia
request a freedom of information act
request to see the results of the prr
again the um the analysis the cdc has
said it would be doing
on the mrna coveted vaccines
the agency wrote quote no prrs were
conducted by cdc
furthermore data mining is outside of
the agency's purview
the agency then suggests contacting the
u.s food and drug administration
which was supposed to perform a
different type of data mining
so this is
jaw
i mean it can't really be a shock to any
of us who've been paying attention to
the absolutely unprecedented adverse
event signal in the vares system and
have been saying
all right we keep we are told that the
system which was set up to detect
adverse events um is not reliable but
then if that's true if they're not
paying attention to this system are they
paying attention to no system
because
it would certainly seem that you would
need to have something monitoring
adverse events in order to know whether
these highly novel vaccines were doing
some
new major kind of damage
what we have in this case is we've got
the cdc telling us exactly what analysis
they were going to perform
when we in the public perform that
analysis we get a very alarming answer
for these vaccines and then when a
freedom of information act request is
directed at the cdc who has told us that
they intended to perform these analyses
the result is they tell us well they
didn't do it which means that apparently
the cdc
was not addressing the question of the
unprecedented adverse event signal from
these vaccines and was simply proceeding
as if it didn't exist this is well going
into public with the talking heads the
people who may have the right
credentials but don't seem to know
anything about how to do science or what
what it would mean to do so
making claims like on april 27 2021 cdc
director dr rochelle balenski stating
that the cdc does not see any signals
relating to heart inflammation
well on what basis can that clean be
made if they're doing no analysis at all
right i mean you know
did you look in the couch cushions for
no heart inflation right there's no
evidence of heart inflammation in these
couch cushions
right so the point is okay you've got
people who are charged with protecting
us from adverse events you've got a
system that was set up which frankly is
set up in such a way that it is very
difficult even for damaging vaccines
just to trigger enough uh of a signal to
to get anyone's attention and in this
case you have an outscaled signal which
does show up in this system does not
appear to be anomalous to the extent
it's been looked at
who filed these reports it's
overwhelmingly medical professionals and
people
involved in pharmaceutical production
themselves who have filed these reports
it is a match for what we see in the
british yellow card system there's all
kinds of evidence that suggests that
there's a very serious adverse event
problem and those who are charged with
balancing the risks of a vaccine with
the benefits of that vaccine are
apparently blinding themselves to the
very signal that they would need to
analyze in order to decide whether or
not the cost was
worth enduring in order to get the
benefit
and
you know well go ahead well i just an
image just came to my mind you know we
we hear terms that are used somewhat
metaphorically like rudderless the
system seems rudderless
perhaps it's leaderless where there's
just a head there
and i think i think rudderless is wrong
i feel like
uh to the extent that a boat with a
rudder metaphor is apt here
there's a rudder
and there's someone in charge and
they've been told just crank it all the
way one way
no matter what the rudder's intact and
we're just going to steer the ship that
way that way that way always the same
way
and
uh it's not that
it's not random
right the the
the
bad information and bad public health
policy and just bad all the way down
almost with regard to responses to covid
at the public policy and public health
level have been
not chaotic
they have been not random they have been
not arbitrary they always air in the
same directions
and that is what suggests
that
we are not rudderless and we are not
leaderless but we are definitely being
driven
we are being driven and we are being
driven in a way that
puts us in peril in other words when
they said safe and effective those were
effectively going to be the conclusions
irrespective of what the evidence
suggested right here we now find out
what safe means which is
it means that they
wrote that into the brochure that was at
best their hope of what would be true
and then they steadfastly
uh
avoided the evidence that would tell
them if they had been incorrect about it
right safe safe as far as we could tell
before we had any data and then we
stopped checking
yeah it's it's it's uncle
if even like that even maybe a generous
interpretation from what we are now
seeing about early results out of the
pfizer trials right yeah
the other thing and the reason that this
connects to the prior two topics is that
we
are in a polarized environment where
those of us who have attempted to
[Music]
divine what is actually true about the
costs and benefits of these vaccines
about the hazards of this disease about
the way in which you might risk stratify
people and protect many people who don't
need the vaccines because they're
protected by virtue of being
young and healthy right we have been
demonized
we have been demonized on the basis that
we misunderstood the evidence when in
fact what we are now finding out is that
there was an effort not to see the
evidence that you know of course it
should shock no one that demonizing us
was part of preventing that evidence
from being scrutinized by anyone and the
question is what do we now do about it
if this is what the cdc does
then
what even is it
what even is it what you know what what
even is it
uh
from which agencies and on what basis
were legions really almost all of the
doctors
being given their marching orders which
then even
even normally free thinking
often heterodox very qualified to think
scientifically scientists and
researchers themselves said wow this is
a complex landscape i'm going to listen
to my doctor well if the doctors
themselves have been given information
that was incomplete that was dogmatic
that would not change at the face of
evidence
then those scientists who are trusting
their doctors are not acting
scientifically they're acting as if the
authorities would not lie to them and
could not be wrong and so that that is
where we find ourselves now that those
that those
those few of us
who are many more than than than
mainstream media would have you believe
but those few of us who stuck our necks
out and said publicly over and over and
over again actually this doesn't add up
these policies don't seem to be a match
for what we can see and science doesn't
work that way and there's no way that
consensus could have been arrived at so
quickly and have it be a legitimate
scientific consensus those of us who did
that and were you know and were thrown
to the bus and demonetized and told that
we were killing people and all of this
as more and more evidence suggests that
actually
the analysis either hasn't been being
done or when it is being done it
suggests exactly the things that those
of us who have been warning about it
were correct
what now
like
fast forward in five years the next one
of these happens
where are the people who are actually
doing the science
and can understand the science well
enough to communicate to people
who are going to be making public
policies because if it's the same people
with the same systems in place we are in
exactly as much trouble as we were
before and even more actually because
now it's really clear
what proportion of the population is
willing to say okay whatever you say
i'll accept i'll accept your thing
i trust you
well
there's that
for the next pandemic there's also the
question i mean
what i don't yet hear
is
a mutiny
right the doctors who were effectively
dragged into gaslighting people who were
injured on the pretense that
adverse events were actually very rare
and therefore most of the people who
walked through the doors of their
doctor's office and said i'm suffering
from this vaccine were effectively
turned away told that it was a
coincidence told that it was in their
heads right where are the doctors who
should be rising up and
uh demanding that the cdc be replaced by
an actual cdc
right that
that absence i mean you know who knows
this is a new a new result but i i am
not really expecting to see the doctor
stand up because the doctors have been
dragged into something unholy and you
know the question is which
which thing will now drive them will
they be driven
by the hippocratic oath and the fact
that they have been forced or induced to
violate it by a cdc that was only
pretending to be interested in
adverse events
will they be driven by their conscience
now or will they be driven by covering
their asses and not admitting to all of
the patients that they turned away and
shouldn't have
that in fact they screwed up and there
are adverse events there are lots of
them and these people need to be treated
we need to have you know effectively uh
a rapid bootstrapping of the medicine of
treating the adverse events that come
from these highly novel vaccines
so i guess time will tell
um but i'm concerned that
everybody has gotten so used to
parroting the official narrative
that
this is even though it is obviously
jaw-dropping that the cdc
apparently violated its own plan for
monitoring adverse events and didn't
monitor them at all
i'm concerned that that will be treated
as just another
minor anomaly here when in fact it is an
indication of exactly what's gone wrong
indeed
i think that may wrap it up all right i
think i think that we are there
which means that
uh we are going to take a short break
and then we'll be back with a live q a
where you can ask questions at
darkhorseadmissions.com
you can are encouraged to join our
patreons if you are so inspired where
tomorrow there will be a live private q
a from 11 a.m pacific until 1
and in the meantime
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]